qu'est-ce tu fous
ici qu'est-ce que tu fous ici je fais
mes courses faut pas gueuler comme ça tu
fais coursouon fait nos courses tien du
coin pas où a le rayon roquette je me
prends pas pour un con je prends pour un
con
e j'ai réfléchi à ce que tu avais dit tu
vois que les gens viennent ici parce qu'
ils viennent chercher la vie et ben en
dormant je me suis dit tu as raison il
viennent chercher un peu de fraîcheur
quand il fait chaud un peu de chaleur
quand quand il fait froid bah j'ai dit
ça c'est bien ça pourquoi je serais le
seul cour à rester en centr-ville donc
je suis venu faire mes courses je te
préviens bonoît si jamais note je
m'appelle pas je m'appelle not non c'est
important ça si jamais tu fous la merde
frèreou pas frère je préviens la S
direct
compris c'est clair ça ou c'est pas mon
ça VI làdans c'est clair tu as compris
la merde rien à [__] du FR Ren àoutre
Ren àoutre c'est ça les règles la norme
Ren à fre du frère sécurité
directile attention Ren à [__]
téléphone